في اخر تطورات الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاده
افادت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه هانا
ماليار افادت ان قوات كييف استعادت قريه
رابعه وهي ستوروغوف الواقعه في اقليم
دونسك بجنوب شرق البلاد من ايادي القوات
الروسيه
وكانت قد اعلنت استعاده ثلاث قرى هي
بلاهودان
في
ووفق مسؤولين اوكران ما زالت المعارك
العنيفه مستمره في بخمه شرقا اوكرانيا مع
تاكيدهم على تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه 700
متر باتجاه المدينه
واوضح المسؤولون ان القوات الروسيه قصفت
مواقعهم اكثر من 200 مره
بينما دمرت القوات الاوكرانيه مركبتين
قتاليتين للقوات الروسيه ومدفعي هاون
ومستودعا للذخيره
في المقابله اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان قواتها صدت محاولات القوات الاوكرانيه
لمهاجمه منطقتي دونسك
وقالت انها ضربت اهدافا بصواريخ عاليه
الدقه اطلقتها من البحر
وقال المتحدث باسم الوزاره
الضربه حققت اهدافها ودمرت جميع المرافق
المحدده لهذا الاستهداف
من موسكو ينضم اليل مزيد من المتابعه
مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد رشد عبد الجواد
اهلا وسهلا بك جديد اخبار المعارك عبد
الجواد وهل صحيح ان كيف استعاده اربع قرى
في دوناتسك هل علقت موسكو على هذا الكلام
مرحبا طالب موسكو لم تعلق رسميا على قضيه
القرى التي يتحدث عنها الجانب الاوكراني
بالرغم من ان بعض وسائل الاعلام غير
الحكوميه قامت بنشر مثل هذه الاخبار
الطالبه بيان وزاره الدفاع الاخير لم
يتطرق لهذا الموضوع لكن كما هو ملاحظ من
هذا البيان وحسب الكثير من التحليلات
السياسيه في البلاد فان موسكو عادت
لاستخدام ضرباتها الصاروخيه التي توجه من
داخل البحر من على السفن الى مناطق مختلفه
يدور الحديث عن استهداف مناطق عسكريه
اوكرانيه بالاضافه الى نقاط حيويه على
محاور عده بالاضافه الى صد هجمات مختلفه
ابرزها يكمن في كراسن في
زبروجي في محور
وفي محور من الشيعه الغربيه
يعني الجهه الغربيه الشماليه كما يقول
يعني تم اسقاط اربع مسيرات اوكرانيه حسب
روايه الدفاع طالب في المقاطعات الاربعه
اما في النقاط الساخنه على الشريط الحدودي
الفاصل بين روسيا واوكرانيا فخرج عمده
وحاكم وتحدث عن ان اعداد الضربات
الاوكرانيه على هذا الاقليم انخفضت بشكل
كبير ولم تتعدى حاجز الخمسه والاربعين
ضربه خلال الساعات الاربعه والعشرين
الماضيه كما هو ملاحظ من الانبا الوارده
من هناك طالب فان احدى المسيرتين التي تم
ايصالها الى منطقه قد استهدفت قطارا كان
يسير وخرجت عرباته بالاضافه الى تضرر
السكك الحديديه هناك لقطات طبعا قامت
حكومه بنشرها طالب تظهر دمرا بالقرب من
محطه دانيسك للسكك الحديديه العديد من
المحال التجاريه تضررت هناك لكن كل هذا
طالب ياتي على التصريحات السياسيه التي
خرج بها
وتحدث وحديث هذا يعتبر نادرا بما يخص
الضربات الاوكرانيه والعمليه العسكريه
بتفاصيلها تحدث بان كيف تقوم باستهداف
المناطق السكنيه يعني بالرغم من ان هذا لا
يعني شيئا في عمليه الصراع العسكريه نقطه
اخيره لو سمحت بها طالب ايضا يدور الحديث
من حكومه بيلغراد بان مناطق تواجد
اللاجئين يتم استهدافها في بعض الاحيان ان
كانوا لاجئين في المناطق التي تم اخراج
اليها سكان المناطق التي عانت من
الفيضانات او اللاجئين في تفضل طالب هل
يرى المسؤولون الروس ان الهجوم المضاد
اصيب بابتكاسه كبرى عبد الجواد ام لا يعني
ينتظرون ويقولون ان هذه المساله لم تتمظهر
بشكل كبير بعد باختصار
طالب يعني رغم الاعلان عن ان موسكو تحضر
لهجوم قد يكون مضاد لكن طبعا على الصعيد
الرسمي على كافه التحليلات السياسيه
الثقيله ان صح التعبير في البلاد فان
موسكو اليوم تسعى لمد واحكام القبض على
خطها الدفاعي لابعاد القوات الاوكرانيه
قدر الامكان عن المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
موسكو في الجنوب الاوكراني لذلك الحديث عن
الهجوم المضاد تتحدث عنه وزاره الدفاع
بشكل يومي مجلس الامن الخارجيه والكرملين
لكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم تعرف ما هي طريقه
الرد التي ستقوم بتقديمها موسكو خلال
الفترات القادمه لكن حسب التحليلات
السياسيه كما ذكرت موسكو ذاهبا نحو احكام
القبض على خطها الدفاعي لابعاد القوات
الاوكرانيه قدر الامكان نحو الشمال من
موسكو مراسل العربي عبد الجواد الرشود
شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الجواد على هذه
المشاركه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات